a great article called do umpires dream
of electronic strikes now Brockman do
you ever see Blade Runner no the movie
Blade Runner is amazing hold that you
need to check it out it was based on a
philip k dick a book called Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep I believe this
has to be this has to be a Blade Runner
reference and I don't not every article
think headline is written by the actual
author of the piece so my apologies to
bleach report Scott Miller to start with
this question here on the Rich Eisen
show is that a is that a Blade Runner
referenced at the top of your article
Scott Mikey there I don't know IIIi I
always tell my editors when I file a
story I'm like look the story that's my
strong suit in terms of headlines like
sometimes I'll write headline or put a
picture in the store in the queue and
[ __ ] we file these things but I saw my
editor look you know the headline and
the art that those are just placeholders
if you like it use it if you don't do
your own thing and this was them doing
their own thing well but yeah it could
be it's it's a very old-school headline
from no doubt millennial there at the
Bleacher Report who put that at the top
so let's get right let's get right into
it Scott cuz I must profess I've heard
about the fact that that Major League
Baseball is kicking the tires on having
some form of a robotic device call a
strike or a ball instead of a home plate
umpire but maybe this is naive I
honestly thought I meant like an actual
robot behind home plate this includes a
human element as well I give you the
floor as to what this system that you've
written about is all about Scott yeah in
in first hop you're not alone right I
think a lot of people you hear robo op
it and you know you expect a full-blown
robot to be standing behind the home
plate which by the way probably would be
pretty entertaining in and of itself but
no it refers to the electronic strike
zone which is a system of lasers it
essentially uses the technology that
baseball is
using at the major-league level for
things like to measure exit velocity of
hits and and you know speed launch
angles and and and you know statcast
stuff about how fast is the outfielder
cover twenty yards it's it's kind of the
same idea only you know used as at home
plate so what happens it's a real live
on pyre just like we're used to seeing
standing behind home plate and he's got
an earpiece in and what happens is this
Trackman system with lasers and such
that is calibrated to measure the strike
zone a pitch arrives and the umpire gets
something in his earpiece strike ball or
no track no track is what it sounds like
it's like I died on it the lasers missed
that one they should miss too many so
the umpire then says ballers strike now
the umpire has to still be very alert
because things come up such as you know
the old check swing at the plate a
batter starts this offer at a pitch and
then holds up well the electronic strike
zone doesn't tell the umpire that's a
strike or a ball it tells him where the
pitch was okay that if that was a strike
but the umpire still got to say okay
decide was that check swing a strike or
did he hold up in time and it's a fall
so you know it can get a little tricky
and the last right they're hoping to use
it in the Atlantic League the whole
second half of the season one of the
most recent delays for example was the
system all works on a Wi-Fi right the
umpire has an iPhone in his pocket and
the earpiece is here
well most recent delays they found when
the umpire strayed too far from home
plate if you had to jog down to first
base to you know change video make a
call or just as the play went on he was
leaving the Wi-Fi area so one of the
most recent the ladies was they had to
put extended Wi-Fi in each ballpark so
there's a lot of moving parts to this
and they
cause watching it closely baseball's
helping the Atlantic League Atlantic
leagues kind of the research and
development area so to speak of MLB and
if they like what they see then you know
I don't know if it's gonna be next year
but in the near future we could could
see this at the major league level Wow
Scott Scott Miller a national MLB
columnist for bleacher report with a
fascinating article that's on bleeped
report today about the electronic strike
zone that's being tested right now and
man you spoke to saw young Award winners
in Sabathia Scherzer also Kluber you
spoke to studs of the game at the plate
like Yelich and Hosmer Lucroy as a
catcher what are you what's the sense to
players like this possibility to come to
the major league level Scott it's pretty
mixed and it's pretty interesting in
that what I found for example talking to
Corey Kluber out of players pitchers and
hitters agree that because everybody
your first move
just like you rich and what you do and
me and what I do it's human nature like
your first reaction almost everything is
okay how's this gonna affect me right I
mean sure there is an iron Miller and
Rich and Eisen yes I agree yeah yeah so
who would the strike zone the electronic
strike zone benefit the most most
hitters and pitchers everybody agrees it
could benefit the pitchers because as
Corey Kluber said there are certain
pitches especially mostly the curveball
that may clip the very front of the
electronic strike zone and so it could
be called a strike but then as it curves
it say it it could even bounce on the
plate or bounce just behind the plate so
with real umpires regular umpires that
pitch is almost always called a ball
well in this setup it could be called a
strike and as Corey Kluber said an other
pitcher said that pitch is going to be
impossible
hit so like that's one potential glitch
of this system now Corey Kluber you
would think would be god yes I want this
electronic strike zone I'm going to get
so many more strikes Cooper said I
really don't want it he said it could
benefit pitchers uh in situations like I
just laid out but he said I just think
it takes the human element away from the
game and I'm not sure that that would be
a good thing and pitchers could really
manipulate this thing so even though a
handful of pitchers think it could help
them some don't want it now CC Sabathia
the Yankees pitcher that's retiring
after this year he's absolutely in favor
of it and some hitters are as well
Eric Hosmer as you mentioned I thought I
spoke with him and you know his attitude
is look if we can if baseball can get
this thing you know to where it's is
close to 100% accurate it's possible he
said I'd be all for it because you know
like everybody you know even though it
could benefit pitchers you know hitters
look at their own situation and they
remember all the times they were called
out on hurts that they say that was two
inches outside so some hitters want it
some don't some pitchers wanted some
don't you know there's a whole lot of
debate right now around the game it's
very interesting debate I might add
Scott Miller a bleacher report do
umpires dream of electronic strikes his
newest piece on bleacher report just
right now just out today here on the
Rich Eisen show so just to walk through
it here an umpire that has the air pod
in his ear has a device an actual iPhone
in his pocket so you got the baseball's
in one pocket you got the iPhone and the
other pocket you're hearing into the air
pod some other human being up behind
home plate in the press box a ball
strike no track and with no track the
umpire will have to rely on his actual
old school for the last hundred plus
years calling balls and strikes with his
eyes that's the way it works that's the
way the system works Scott yep pretty
much except the voice he hears in his in
his ears and electronic voice it's not
another human being at the other end of
that is that the the the lasers are
calibrated and then feed into the
electronic system and then the
electronic system spent sound strike
ball or no track so okay so then it's
possible is it possible Scott for the no
track to basically throw your arms up
you can have that as the voice of Joe
West can Joe West do that like so you
can actually request what the voice is
can you do that if it's a Miss pitch
it's the voice of angel Hernandez what
do you think Scott can we do that you
know what you went from Blade Runner
possibility that might make a hundred
percent of the major leaguers say we
don't want this if it's gonna be the
voice of a jar well in that respect you
quote it you quote you got a comment
from the umpires Association saying in
part that the entire major league
baseball umpire staff averaged over
ninety seven percent correct ball and
strike calls over the 2018 season I
could probably put together a video of
Hernandez missing four percent of those
Scott I mean you know how does this get
reconciled umpires saying what they're
saying MLB wanting to be perfect players
and cut you know and pitchers saying
something else how does it all get
reconciled best to your reporting and
seeing everything out there yeah well
yeah yeah it's like a good old-fashioned
negotiations I think and it's
interesting as well
because one other angle to this the
Major League umpires is you would expect
a very very wary of this I mean that you
know and like anybody as it should be
when you know they take pride in their
jobs and they think they're the very
best in the world even if they miss some
striking ball calls here and there and
they are very good almost all of them so
they take pride in their job and and
like a lot of us okay good so now
computers might come and take our jobs
as well so they're worried but as is the
scenarios we talked about obviously you
you're always going to still need
umpires just even for the check swing
example I gave you but what's
interesting as well one other layer down
beneath the surface to this is the cot
yet we hear so much about the owners and
players when their basic agreement comes
up and I'll G's the current deal goes
through whatever year well the deal
between baseball and the umpires union
is up after this year this is a
negotiating here right now well between
you know the Commissioner's Office and
baseball and the umpires union so this
adds a layer to that and I'm not sure
hope that you know management is able to
hold this over the umpires or that I
don't think the electronic strike zone
is developed quite to the point there
it's not ready to be implemented next
year so you know they can't tell the
umpires sign this bill or you're all
going to be gone in place of robots but
that's another layer that adds some
tension to the negotiations right now as
well so then last one for you if you
will ballpark it for me Scott Miller a
bleacher report if at all let's just say
the umpires say okay when when and and
when does Major League Baseball envision
bringing this to the major league level
Scott yeah they it they don't have a
date in mind yet they would like this to
work and work well and then I would say
it would be in the near future but you
know how complicated this is this was
supposed to have started in the Atlantic
League at the beginning of the year in
April and they had a handful of delays
even up to and including what I said
they figured out as they were trying to
get this going that they needed to set
up not just Wi-Fi but extended Wi-Fi for
when the home plate umpire rolls out of
this area so they were not able to get
this going until recently they tested it
out in a Long Island Ducks
in Somerset game and then they are
Balak kind of the big public bells and
whistles on bailing was just last
Wednesday at the Atlantic League
all-star game they're hoping to run it
all through the second half of the year
it's not in the Atlantic League is an
independent professional league right so
the minor leagues it's not running yet
in any of the minor league system so
they're trying to work out all the kinks
this year so the next step if they can
get the kinks worked out then would be
to move it into some minor leagues and
then make sure they get it up and going
there and they would have to run those
tests in the minor leagues before it
will come to the major so if everything
goes well could be in the major leagues
you know I'm gonna say maybe within
three years or so so I mean it's not
that far out but if the tests don't go
well you know it could be delayed a
little bit beyond that but it's
definitely something that MLB is
investing much time and money into and
you know how that goes once you start
investing money in they're not doing it
just for fun that's right Scott great
piece thanks for calling hopefully this
first and many times you you call into
the show thanks again
my pleasure rich thank you you got a
Scott Miller or bleacher report do
umpires dream of electronic strikes for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app